se acerca el desenlace presidencial en
chile una cita clave pero para muchos
chilenos un tema menor como demuestra el
más de 52% de abstencionistas de la
primera vuelta así lo analizó para
france24 marta lagos directora del
latinobarómetro sería la primera vez que
visualizamos la posibilidad de que vote
menos gente que en la segunda vuelta que
en la primera vuelta en medio de este
clima a las tres principales encuestas
dan como vencedor al ex líder
estudiantil izquierda gabriel boric
opinión que comparte marta lagos hay hoy
día un ambiente electoral un ánimo no
septo de que boris tendría
posibilidades altas de ganar el día el
día domingo este jueves además ambos
candidatos vivieron sus cierres de
campaña el ultraderechista josé antonio
kast escogió la capital santiago cas
venció la primera vuelta con el 27 9% de
los votos pero ha querido centrar su
discurso final en su rival porque eso lo
que conoce la izquierda usar la
violencia como herramienta política y
nosotros no se lo vamos permitir nunca
más nos vamos a rendir frente a la
intolerancia a la izquierda desde
casablanca comuna de valparaíso boris
optó por una estrategia bien distinta y
continuó con su tendencia de las últimas
semanas de mostrarse como un candidato
de unidad
somos herederos
las luchas del pueblo de chile
somos herederos de lo que cayeron
luchando por una sociedad distinta y hoy
día no solo excesivo con mucha humildad
aquí estamos para hacer esos sueños
realidad moritz se acercó en la primera
vuelta a la ola del estallido social de
chile de 2019 mientras que en esta
segunda vuelta ha buscado ampliar sus
bases y tras recibir apoyos como el de
la ex presidenta michelle bachelet ha
conseguido tomar una ligera ventaja